our animal people missing something
there are animal people and then there
are crazy [ __ ] like Joe our
wannabe animal people the hardcore
animal people that do it for a living
and it's their whole life they're
they're of a very specific ilk I know
guys that it means everything to them
they do not party they aren't going out
they're not crazy guys they live and
breathe for the wildlife in their care
those guys are of a very disciplined ilk
just like people that are really into
their art of any form the art takes over
and working big that's in contact is
very much an art what Cody's doing on
there that is art that to be that guy
and not be getting eaten up not get
scratched I've got all my fingers and
toes I've never been hurt in my life
I've had 400 that's playing with me
since I was in my early 20s and have had
no troubles with it that's an art form
and a science that you're going through
that requires your full attention
those guys Wow you know I mean Joe is by
his own admission gun-toting gay drug
addict wild man looking for the next big
party you know that's how he self
describes right and a lot of the
characters with him are wild his current
husband is a pretty mild mannered
sweetheart guy seems like he's not on
that vibe at all and I think Joe is
drifting in his late 50s to be more of
an easygoing guy man Joe in his 40s was
wow that's trouble can I get in and who
wants to join yeah and Carol is in my
opinion full-blown psychotic
you know creepy woman in the background
I said she's walking around saying
Redrum Redrum he's out of her gourd you
know you know what happened Carol killed
her [ __ ] husband
you know the series took it to town it's
crazy like like it was I mean the my
buddy said I got I got it I got a
attribute this to my buddy Akash but he
had this great point he goes we were
discussing who lost the most from this
right and and he goes Carol and I go
really why do you think that and he goes
think about it she needs to be loved she
needs to be adored like she didn't get
in this to like save cats she got in
this because she's the good person
that's helping the animals and now the
entire world thinks she killed her
[ __ ] husband so even though she's not
in prison she's probably the most
tortured by this documentary right you
know and the greatest goal of Joe's life
was twofold
get famous and to [ __ ] up Carol basket
he's more famous than anybody you see in
this situation wouldn't matter if he had
a hit movie he wouldn't be this famous
you know he's more famous than the rock
is today